Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters here and you are at
Do look a do look at cancer a series that we're gonna do
Actually, don't know how many sessions this could be because I've already I have created several dozen of them
So stay tuned we got a lot to go through in this program
So this is session number one. I'm gonna try to keep these short keep your attention
With me so session number one and a do look at cancer. So
Why do we need a do look at cancer? Well a few reasons maybe a few hundred million reasons
What out of 2.5 Americans will get cancer? That is
2010 statistics you cannot help
Getting this throat at you and you get thrown into this because you every single person probably listening to this
Either has cancer or that's why you're listening to this or a loved one has cancer or even if
You don't into the whole cancer seed you are gonna be exposed to people that have cancer. It is just there's no getting around it
One on a two mid one on a three women in America will have cancer in their lifetime
It's kind of crazy because
It just wasn't that way so
Even back in the 1970s and the 1960s I think in the in the 50s
It was one out of 80 Americans got cancer. It's just been
growing
It wasn't even in the top 10 causes of death and as though the second cause of death behind heart disease
Here's one of my quotes. I am more fully convinced that I'll the alternative model, which is really the integrative model for cancer
Is really not optional. It is the medical model that is optional. What do we really look at how we're going to take care of somebody with cancer?
But in fact, this is president Nixon's address. This is a very famous picture of him signing in
To as a bill the war on cancer and he came out with a presidential address
Say that in 10 years that we will have cancer
Conquered and a cure found for cancer. He put an extra hundred million dollars to lodge a
Huge campaign to cure cancer to find the cause of cancer
This was in 1971 and at that time one in 21 Americans would get cancer in
1971 how many years ago was that?
50 years ago 40 years ago
Now it's one in two point five Americans get cancer
From one in 20 to one in two point five if this was a war on cancer
We are getting slaughtered in this war and a hundred million dollars to lodge an intensive campaign to fight a cure for cancer
That is a drop in the bucket. What is
collected to
To fund research programs to fight a cure for cancer
There are never going to fight a cure for cancer. There is too much money in cancer
That's that's just the way it is
Heart disease over the course of between
1950 and 2005 the rate of heart disease per hundred thousand
dropped less than 50 percent
We are doing a great job with heart disease
cerebral vascular diseases that are strokes
It dropped
huge amount
Fluid influenza pneumonia infectious diseases dropped less than more than a half and yet cancer hardly made a blip
What is going on with cancer?
We are losing the war on cancer
Again
1971 wanted 20 Americans today wanted to point five
The incidence up 18 percent death rate is up 1.3 percent
Regardless of what you hear on television that we are making strides with cancer
We are simply making strides with earlier detection
You realize from a medical standpoint if you got cancer today
And in five years from today you are still alive
Though you were in hospice care in your last two weeks of life
And you passed today you would be considered cured of cancer even though you might die
Five years in one day after the first incidence of the first diagnosis you are still considered a cancer cure
So this is how they fudge the statistics
There has been literally no significant changes in survival rate over the last 25 years
in our treatment of cancer
The serious clinician will come to a conclusion that's successful
Supportive care of somebody diagnosed with cancer will be defined as converting it from a acute terminal illness
Be that you are going to die to from it to a chronic manageable disorder
And that's what we really want
I never I think it is a disservice to tell a person that they have that they're cured of cancer
That is a complete dissert disservice because it is not true
We all have cancer cells growing in our body at all times
And what our purpose is is a clinician is to take that person who's going down hill and losing this battle
The cancer is taking over their body and it's going to put them in the grave
To now we can manage it
The body is winning the battle
It's killing the it's killing those cancer cells
And the person is recovering
But this is a lifelong this is a lifelong battle
So it's a lifelong lifestyle change of doing the right things to keep the immune system stimulated to get rid of the cause
To to stimulate the immune system to be able to fight this disorder
So that now they can manage it and they can live a nice low life the way God intended them
That is our goal not to cure anything
It's to help their body overcome the disorder
So what is cancer? We're going to spend a few weeks on this
Cancer is the abnormal growth of different cells
So it's not cells that came from outside of your body
It's your old tissue cells
So if it's cancer in the liver
It is a liver cell that didn't go through apoptosis or normal program cell death
It didn't die
Secondly, they're the defect inside the cell
That is caused from a bunch of different possible things that we're going to talk about in this series
The defect of the cell not only stopped the apoptotic process
Stopped it from dying when it should die
But it caused the mutation so that the cell is now at a rapid replication state
So normally a liver cell would reproduce about every 12 weeks
And the mother cell would die
Now the mother cell is not dying
It's reproducing 12 times a day
And it's reproducing cells that have the same abnormal gene structure
So it's reproducing cells that don't die
And are at a rapid replication state
So they don't act like liver cells
So the more tissue that they take out
Take up you have less liver
And you die of liver cancer
So understating those two pathway breakdowns
We can look at some nutraceutical approaches
That can help us reverse that
That can stimulate your immune system to kill the cancer
So here's a normal cell
You adapt with an abnormal cell that turns into a cancer
That then gets a blood supply and is able to grow and produce
But it started with a normal cell
The cell stopped doing what a normal cell should do
Two things happened with a cancer cell
Again, it didn't go through a normal program cell death
And it went into a rapid replication stage
That's what cancer is
Doesn't die
And it's in rapid replication
And then it's replicated cells that do exactly that same thing
Well, there is always a reason why
And if you ask your oncologist
An oncologist, why do I have cancer
You're going to get a blank stare
And usually they'll say it's a genetic thing
Well, we'll clear that up also
But there's a reason why that those processes were broken
So cancer develops
The normal cell becomes a cancer cell
Because of a genetic change
That happened something from the environment
That's what we'll be talking about through the series
If it begins doubly and replicating and replicating
That's what a malignant tumor is
So we'll talk about how it progresses next week as we go
I'm trying to keep these short
And keep your attention
If this is all due to you, listen to it again
Otherwise, we'll see you next week